thank you you came directly from Kabul
yes how would tell me you've been there
for seven years now how did you end up
there in the first place well I
originally went in 2008 I went there to
train and mentor Afghan defense
attorneys with the program that was
funded by the u.s. Department of State
to be honest I really went there for the
money because it was making
significantly more than what I had been
making as a US attorney at the time and
so that's what got me in Afghanistan in
2008 and what did you know about
Afghanistan I mean were you familiar
with the with the country no I I wasn't
familiar with Afghanistan at all in fact
I had never left the u.s. until 2008
Afghanistan was the first country that
ever traveled to out of the US so I was
very fresh and I don't know a lot were
you were you like were you anxious I
mean it's it can be a dangerous place
yeah I can be I was anxious you know I I
just didn't know what to expect and
obviously when you watch the news or
when you hear about Afghanistan it's not
in a very positive light so of course I
was a little concerned but I was very
curious about how the country was today
warn you like it should be careful or
well you know when when I went there in
oh wait they have this training that I
was sent through and it's very
Manchurian Candidate ish where they show
you there's one point at the training
for about four hours where they showed
us videos of things and people that have
been blown up presumably in Afghanistan
and so the training was ridiculous and
that but that's what they sort of showed
us you know so literally when I went to
Afghanistan I really felt like I was
going to you know walk off the airplane
and a suicide bomber was gonna try to
come up to me and give me a hug so it
was very terrifying at first this is I
mean African law that's very much a
man's world is my impression anyway how
do you how do you find your place there
well I mean um you know I am Who I am
and you know now
I work independently so I have an
independent law firm that I work from in
Afghanistan and so I just you know I
represent my clients I'm there to you
know be their lawyer so I just do what I
do and I don't really ask for their
permission to give me a place do you do
you wear a headscarf do you why is that
um you know I don't do it to be
disrespectful it's just not my thing you
know and I always felt like if I'm gonna
practice law in Afghanistan then I need
to be Who I am and that's not what I do
and so that's why I don't do it do they
I mean the people you deal with do they
respect but or is it can it be a problem
for you well it hasn't been a problem
for me you know not nothing where anyone
has brought it to me and I don't allow
for it to be a problem to be honest you
have you have typical
doing all kinds of cases I mean you
don't you're not a human rights activist
you're a traditional lawyer taking all
kinds of cases can you tell us a bit
about that what kind of clients you you
you choose well my clients I'm an
international litigator and so I love to
go to court in all different countries
Afghanistan is obviously a place I go to
court a lot and so my clients consist of
a lot of companies that I represent
around the world
I represent several embassies and
ambassadors in Afghanistan
I represent foreigners for different
legal our criminal offenses in
Afghanistan and beyond and I also
represent a huge portion of human rights
clients mostly women and children and
that's about 30 percent of my work and I
do that work pro bono and so the the
other clients are bread and butter and
then they have right exactly
clients as well right and I have those
pro bono clients are all around the
world and so now thanks to what has
started in Afghanistan you know I have
clients on every continent except for
Antarctica which I would love to get a
client in Antarctica to just check that
box but you know my sort of my pro bono
human rights clients those are really
you know my heart and soul and so I fund
that all myself through my bread and
butter clients when you work on a case
can you like like Gundam was telling us
about earlier that he visualizes you
know he visualize how how it will end is
I mean if it's a competition or if it's
making a world hit or whatever can you
visualize as well I don't the result I I
was listening and I totally understand
that I definitely you know I feel like
litigation is really an art it's a craft
you know just like performing as an
artist just like being an athlete I
think it's it's very artistic to me and
so I do definitely visualize you know
how I'm going to play things out in
court and winning in court I think
that's very important positive thinking
how how corrupt is that
well Afghanistan is one of the most
corrupt countries in the world it's it's
sort of volleys between Somalia North
Korea and Afghanistan for the top three
spot so but I have but however I have
found that if you use the laws in the
ways that they're intended to be used
then you can be successful and I find
that in Afghanistan as well as other
countries that people are very ignorant
to the law they don't know that the laws
are there for them they don't know that
the laws exist and they often allow
themselves to be bullied into
unfortunately having cultural practices
superseded the law and so my job is to
stand up for my clients to not allow for
them to be bullied and to use the laws
in the ways that they're meant to be
used which is to protect my clients and
to protect all of us do you do you ever
have David tried to bribe you have you
experienced that they have tried to
bribe me and it's actually funny because
you know they kind of stop now because
because I don't pay bribes and so I
remember the last time they usually try
to bribe through my cotton through my
translators and so one of the judges was
like you know do Americans accept bribes
and my translator told not this one
you made quite a lot of headlines
internationally especially we won't we
won't case there and it was a six year
old girl and she's called noggin